boulet cat podcast man special guest in
here my guy ot the real what up what up
welcome well first of all man uh you've
been busy this year yeah you already
know you've had a crazy 2021 you're on
the road with benny the butcher right
now yes sir how's the tour been
lit great experience yeah i was telling
you me and benny have had some
conversations about you he's definitely
been a fan for a minute you know what
i'm saying
yeah same here man how long like like
how did you guys end up linking up in in
this in this rap game man um you know we
knew about each other but um we got a
mutual homie um who was actually
supposed to be here today
i mean i
and now you know we just been connecting
the dots you know
any chance that other ends up at bsf
oh no
any discussions
i mean every yeah we're talking about a
whole lot of different stuff all good
business man um you know benny does real
good business and the people around for
sure people that he's with you know what
i'm learning yeah i mean they got the
sports agency they got they got a lot
going on man yeah i'm learning a lot um
what is like something you've learned is
this your first time being on like a
like a big tour like yeah definitely
what is something you've learned that
you didn't really know going into this
tour that you've maybe found out about
yourself or performing or how this [ __ ]
works
well
when jadakiss did that verses
rapping over your lyrics was over with
yeah
that [ __ ] was over with i'm saying and
um i was doing that a lot so when i was
there and i seen that i was like damn i
need to really like i need to tighten up
i remember like going on tour with slain
like a little three cities tour that
slain having shot my guy slaying hell
yeah big shout out sling he got a new
movie coming out too i bet he does ida
red yeah but um
you know rapping over your lyrics the
real hip-hop fans ain't fans of that and
philly and [ __ ] at like showcases and i
get paid to go do some [ __ ] at a club
and they want to play my record so i'm
right that's different yeah but when it
came time to do this tour you know what
i'm saying we sat down and really took
our time with the soundtracks and [ __ ]
so like on this tour you took pretty
much you're just going over your
instrumentals yeah a couple punches i
sat with thorough i sat with my man
thorough and we went over and made the
soundtracks and everything and uh
got that [ __ ] ready
now you got a new tape dropping with
green lantern you were telling me right
yes sir uh
december 10th and is that you are you
getting any green lantern beats because
i was feeling the whole thing's produced
by man green lantern is one of the most
slept on producers shout out to my guy
man hell yeah yeah
shout out green um
got some [ __ ] on there man that's that's
gonna be my fifth take this year
starting the year i dropped with uh
i dropped with big mike the ruler evil
empire
john's a big mike
mixtape og man hell yeah drop then i
dropped the album with uh heat makers
with arsonists i dropped the irishman
i just dropped you are who you eat with
about two months ago and then me and
ball getty just dropped a little ep
on ball getting from out here back then
[ __ ] so
you got a crazy a crazy uh catalog just
this year yeah yeah yeah you know that's
one of the things i've been learning
right it's a catalog that catalog man
it's a residual income every month right
two tapes a year don't do it man yeah i
feel like you know i feel like uh
low-key you know the griselda guys kind
of showed a lot of people the way like
you just got to keep feeding that fan
base 100
over and over man what was it like
working with heat makers because
obviously they're
responsible for kind of being the
architect of like what i would like to
call probably the dip set
peak yeah yeah they did all uh
they were arsonists did uh most of that
stuff man so it's crazy you know i was
in there with like
they got this cat named opera steve over
there
and he's the one who's saying killer cam
oh wow it's crazy because everyone
always thought that was a sample because
it sounds like a sample it's got singers
in there man ours be having
and hey by the way the capo album the
jim jones albums one of them man
craziest albums of 2019 too
yeah for sure definitely is man you know
i was honored to be able to you know
follow up with the album with him after
that you know i'm saying that [ __ ] was
crazy man so that's just still spinning
all platforms the irishman you know
december 10th green lantern what's the
name of the tape broken glass broken
glass with green lantern shout out to my
guy green lantern he's an honorary
arizona uh resident uh yeah he's out in
az that's my hometown you know
well look man we're gonna have you do
what you do and that is
get your [ __ ] off man let's do it
you you mentioned jada's
it's only right oh yeah yeah come on man
other real broken glass december 10th
let's go
solid game who you going to risk it with
here they up early with the poles like a
fishing trip i don't know who shot or
assisted it all i know is sometimes
people had to die and i could live with
it this ain't a tournament keep me out
your brackets the feds playing tennis
keep me out your rackets they asking ot
why you ain't level up in rap yet the
level up is giving those people less
access
still eating off the access is really
real hoping life straightens itself out
like a steering wheel they ask me why
you in the city still the kids playing
modern warfare they out here going kill
for kill
it's a cold world let it feel the chill
and tell that put your hoodie and your
jacket on who'da thought the coke passed
along to make classic songs all i needs
a press and a big table to smack [ __ ] on
my man said the feds really got me he a
million dollar man like ted dibiase the
haze calming down the hand gets me saucy
i don't want that address with state
intersects with ron street welcome to
the war zone i suggest you have one your
best bet don't be celebrating when your
bag comes you ain't seen a bird so you
bagged one kite gave us bad lungs came
home got my license when i'm mad runs
yeah i'm talking balls to the wall there
was no one that could catch me i could
call if i fall in the end we all trying
to ball so live it up my bro took a plea
so the feds couldn't pick it up when you
got kids it's hard not to give a [ __ ]
cause that's what suffers if you get
your life snatched but if it's really
beef it's on for life scrap i'll put a
bag of crystals on his head like an ice
pack wrote a dice back overflow a head
crack haters get caught up and be like
bro i never said that one time we got
robbed by a homie from a squad i brought
guns to his mom's and made that [ __ ]
get the bread back i was really out
there with ounces for eight of one to
one but the plug dropped pounds on my
plate to half price so in the end really
it always the same few in the streets
darn diva is like your hall of fame word
she wanna see the stars in the ceiling
before a rap pop i got it all off the
dylan i just got numb to them all
catching feelings aside from the rats i
hope they all get the millions there's
no hate lawyers told me move at a slow
pace
i learned that no surveillance means no
case now everybody got their own chase
but it's crazy how you could fracture a
track but catch no breaks was in the cut
would blow at the table cutting those 16
couldn't even buy my own buns to roll
but now it's all trucks and loads meet
me at the home depot for these a1s i
don't [ __ ] with lows
a known drug individual love for the
streets but the love ain't reciprocal
grew up on the run [ __ ] was difficult
turn us into goons sneaking strips of
subs in the visit rooms cash flippers
started as crack whippers my fiend keep
hitting the pole like a bad kicker we
wasn't major but had figures i really
had bricks in the back of the black whip
with the bad stickers yeah eating off a
dream i was eating off of fiends now i'm
feeling like a river cause i'm eating
off of streams i'm on the scene my west
coast plugs stay on a bean ran for more
white girl in la then charlie sheen
broken glass december 10th my irish
brother man the irishman other real yeah
you know what it is man that lowe's line
oh man said meet me at the home depot
[ __ ] what you think i got the a1 i don't
[ __ ] with lowe's you know what it is
come on man
december 10th go get that man shout out
my god green lantern other real